nintendo has announced the official
launch date of their new NX console I'm
Dave and welcome to your gamespot news
update Nintendo has confirmed that its
upcoming gaming console codenamed NX
will be launching in March 2017 around
the world the information was revealed
as part of the company's 2016 fiscal
year earnings report released today the
launch date was also confirmed by a post
from the official Nintendo of America
Twitter account the report reads for our
dedicated video game platform business
Nintendo is currently developing a
gaming platform codenamed NX with a
brand-new concept NX will be launched in
march 2017 globally no further details
about the NX or the consoles new concept
were revealed in late 2015 reports from
The Wall Street Journal pointed to a
possible 2016 release date with
allegations that software development
kits are already being sent to
third-party developers the company also
revealed it will be releasing fire
emblem and Animal Crossing games for
mobile devices expanding its repertoire
of apps following the release of
Miyamoto social networking app so you
excited about the release of the NX what
do you think this new concept is let us
know in the comment section below or
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
fraud intendo news stay tuned to
gamespot com